j'ai noté qu'il n'y avait pas de pays
extérieurs
alors je sais pas si vous allez en avoir
besoin mais en tout cas il n'y a pas de
chef
pour l'extérieur a effectivement fait
effectivement on n'y a pas mieux pas
forcément pensé ça date de réception
organisation des menus s'occuper de
l'animation organiser son mariage peut
vite devenir un casse tête pour éviter
que le plus beau jour de sa vie ne
devienne un cauchemar ce client installé
à hong kong a décidé de s'en remettre à
anaïs et florence de wedding planner
leur but réaliser votre rêve pas de prix
value c'est que on va s'occuper tout ni
vont être très serein
il y aura moins de stress parce que ma
forcément il y en a toujours un petit
peu pour un mariage c'est normal mais
voilà on va être là pour les accompagner
et les aider au maximum et surtout ça
soit la décoration le traiteur la salle
de réception un photographe
on s'occupe de tout
voilà un an et demi qu'elle ont ouvert
leurs agences anaïs et florence située à
trappes
les deux organisatrices s'adapte à votre
demande selon la thématique est le mieux
[Musique]
le budget moyen d'un mariage avec 100
invités est d'environ 15000 euros
les wedding planner ont de nombreux
partenariats avec des salles de
réception encore des photographes en
faisant appel à elle vous fait environ
15% d'économies sur votre budget on est
là aussi justement pour négocier les
prix avec les prestataires ce que les
particuliers ne mousse pas ou ne demande
pas forcément donc noah avec avec nos
partenariats du coup on peut justement
essayer de de répondre à leurs critères
en rentrant dans leur budget et c'est ce
qui est assez compliqué de faire quand
on n'a pas de zune canard anaïs et
florence prépare déjà des mariages pour
la saison 2010 8 pour bien organiser
l'événement il faut s'y prendre au moins
un an à l'avancé